Ryan when did you find out about this
story and think that of all the stories
that went on in Guatemala in Central
America in all of Latin America that
could have paralleled this why'd this
one so I didn't know all of those
stories I'll be honest with you I this
story found me as head of the
documentary division for the Kenan
Marshall company I work with Frank
Marshall on a host of documentaries in
one day he came in to my office and said
you got to hear this story and it just
so happens that Frank is lifelong
friends and went to high school with
Scott great head who's the human rights
attorney who ended up representing Oscar
in his political asylum case and so
Scott made Frank aware of this amazing
story of one of his clients and it was
right before Scott Oscar and Freddy
Petrelli the executive director of the
forensic anthropology foundation of
Guatemala were going to be coming to Los
Angeles to go to the Riverside federal
courthouse for the sentencing of one of
these soldiers found living in Southern
California as a u.s. resident and so
Frank encouraged me to grab my camera
and and join and so I met all three of
these men drove out to Riverside with
them sat in the courtroom
as Oscar read this prepared victim
statement did a little bit of filming
before and after and and I came home to
my wife that night and I said I think
I've I think I've just filmed the end to
the most fascinating story I've ever
heard
and I think I'm going to go to Guatemala
I knew after spending that day with
Oscar that that not only was this an
amazing story but here was what I
thought and proved to be pretty close to
the end
you know this incredible tale of justice
seeking justice that starts in the in
the jungles of Guatemala by these
incredible human rights activists and
anthropologists and ends up at decades
later finding this boy now a man
in the suburbs of Boston of all places
and here he is now participating in that
same justice
it's like is documentarians you're not
often given your ending and at the
beginning you often have to wait for
life to evolve and see see where the
story is going to go and at that point
it just seemed like this is this is
where this story is going to end and now
we need to go find the rest of it and
Stephen perhaps you can talk about how
you came to be involved in this project
actually I was on the same visit that
Freddy and Scott made to Riverside that
they came they knew about the project of
the USC Shoah foundation and that Steven
Spielberg has established this archive
to take the testimonies of people who
witnessed the Holocaust and now genocide
other than the Holocaust and so we had a
conversation which also resulted in
planning a trip to Guatemala because you
know the work that Freddy pressure
really was doing on the forensics was
about finding evidence but he was very
aware that also there needed to be voice
and that many of these stories were not
being told so the story that was being
told through their labs was that of
forensic investigation that needed to be
done to it to establish the crime itself
but that the people who had survived did
not have voice at this point and so
actually we ended up on the same trip
together he was scouting with a camera I
was scouting with a camera and we were
in the bottom of the same excavation
during an exhumation one of which you
saw short clip of that Ryan included and
it was kind of in that moment where in
the bottom of this grave with these two
corpses that were being exhumed with the
family around the edge of it that that
kind of combination of justice and truth
telling through investigation and the
need to tell the story became really
clear and so actually this is a really
interesting moment because out of the
making of the film and the process of
making the film we have now
and three hundred and fifty testimonies
of people who are the relatives of those
and are partnered with the forensic
anthropology group there and we've
trained them to become oral historian so
that when they take the evidence and
exhume the evidence they also now
document the personal human story Ryan
last year right here there was a
documentary screened about the Khmer
Rouge killings in Cambodia and it turns
out that some of the people who were
doing the killings still live in the
same villages with people whose family
members they murdered and the the code
of silence endured and endured and then
it started to crack and hearing their
stories was just as compelling from that
point of view as hearing the stories of
the people who were victims a relative
of the victims so how did you get those
stories out of the killers in this case
yeah so I mean we benefited from the
fact that they they had already broken
that code of silence when they offered
their testimony first two or Elena for
fun and then to Sarah Romero and so they
became you know their testimony became
the lynchpin for this investigation
which made it different than any other
investigation because this was not this
this this hadn't happened really in
Guatemala that certainly within the
Kabila's this elite special forces unit
that you had soldiers breaking the code
of silence to come forward and say what
really happened
so that testimony had already been
documented both in the two trials that
that took place in Guatemala and has
since been repurposed we utilized for
the two trials that have happened in the
States we also benefited from the fact
that there was a Pro Publica piece
journalism and a This American Life
story that took place several years ago
and so this wasn't the first time they
had shared their story both in testimony
and in internal istic endeavors however
it was the first time that they were in
front of a camera doing it and and for
me I because I was I was well versed in
what they had said previously I had an
eye
dia of who I was going to be sitting
across from and it was an idea of
somebody who had been involved with the
most horrific of crimes and essentially
was probably some iteration of evil you
know I didn't I didn't really I'd never
really done an interview like those two
interviews and so I as I prepared to to
face somebody who you know was involved
with killing children
the minute both men walked in on the
separate days that we interviewed them I
was reminded of the power of visual
storytelling because I had heard their
stories I had heard their read their
words but seeing them reminded me that
these were human beings this wasn't some
idea of that there is just good and evil
in the world that it is black and white
and and we spoke to them in we got their
story we certainly got them to speak to
what happened at the massacre
but we started at the beginning much
like the the testimony that the Shoah
foundation gets from survivors we
started at the beginning to get a better
understanding of how did this how what
was the circumstance that brought them
through their lives to find themselves
that day involved with this because
clearly something didn't sit right with
them in that they had broken this code
of silence to share this story and and
in no way do do I feel or do I want to
rationalize their culpability away for
what they were involved with but just
having that dialogue gave me an empathy
and a desire to have a better
understanding of how they became who
they became in what they became involved
with because I think if you don't if you
don't understand that or if you don't
try to appreciate that they are just
human beings with the potential for good
and evil within them and within us
that's that's how we are you know doomed
to root
eat this same cycle regardless of what
part of the world or ethnicity your skin
color
might be applied please thank our guests
for this important film